bonsoir je qui bonsoir monsieur savard
ce matin je me suis levé un peu plus tôt
que d'habitude monsieur c'est bien je me
suis regardé dans la glace pendant près
d'une minute
courageux monsieur j'ai remarqué que
ressembler de plus en plus à jean
lefebvre j'ai peur de quoi jeter
je ne sais pas monsieur j'ai peur de
devenir drôle
rassurez-vous jacky vous ne courait
aucun risque merci monsieur
c'est beau
si content d'être là dessus car ça fait
quatre ans que j'ai pas pris de vacances
et puis c'est formidable bruyas père en
dix mois il ya deux personnes quand même
qu'ils sont mortes de rire à cause de
toi
c'est incroyable la première dame qui
est morte de rire
c'est au théâtre des variétés ouais on
joue une pièce qu'ils s'appelaient je
veux voir mioussov elle rit aux éclats
elle était dans les premiers rangs
un dimanche et tout d'un coup j'ai vu
qu'un dollar
et puis est c'est un peu évanoui et on
l'a sorti et à l'entracte j'ai demandé
ce qu'elle avait on n'a pas voulu me le
dire
et la fin du spectacle m'a dit elle est
morte elle est morte c'est à dire que la
pauvre femme
ça te fait rire ce désagrément clients
et elle avait de la ce et en riant elle
s'étaient tous fait la deuxième personne
c'était au théâtre il ya à peu près un
an il ya une dame qui y avait des gens
qui demandaient dédicaces et il y avait
une dame qui était là je suis de voler
une dédicace dont elle ait lieu
je voudrais vous parler personnellement
j'ai souvent défaut l'un est bon tout le
monde a résumé christian malard elle m'a
dit je voulais voir de visu
je dis pourquoi
parce que mon mari est mort à cause de
vous alors c'est très bien qui se veut
répond je je dis à vous devez m'en
vouloir
elle dit non j'avais 40 ans sont mario
une cinquantaine d'années elle me dit
non mon mari était cardiaque dont il y
avait eu un fils qui passait de lautner
mais nous fâchons pas y rit aux éclats
et tout d'un coup animaux l ai dit je
l'aimé beaucoup mais j'ai une
consolation il est mort en riant tu veux
réparer
c'était délicat a dit moi tu es le
recordman français des tournées et
arrêtent pas là tu reprends les jumeaux
mais après tu repars en tournée karsenti
en suisse riche belgique
je viens touche du bois parce que toutes
les pièces que j'ai joués on les a joués
minimum 800 x d'abord parce que je suis
paresseux maman comme ça jusqu'au but
d'apprendre des nouveaux textes et puis
plus on joue plus on améliore un trouve
des trucs et c'est ça qu'il faut remis
d'un mauvais tacle au théâtre plus que
au cinéma parce que si un effet ne
portent pas tu peux le rectifier
alors qu'au cinéma c'est sur la
pellicule tu dis je préférais quand
j'étais fauché parce que maman je peux
plus prendre de vacances ça fait
longtemps que tu as pas pris de vacances
jean quatre ans ah oui c'est beaucoup
quand et mais c'est quand même curieux
parce que je suis en vacances depuis
une dizaine de jours 1 je suis un peu
pour mais tu fais quoi leur compte en
vacances quand je suis en vacances
j'ai une très grande qualité
je suis paresseux et ses carrés ce jeudi
tandis que les paresseux c'est un défaut
qui a plu à paresseux je ne m'ennuie
jamais eu pas de nuit dans les boîtes
c'est un peu si pas je les boîtes j'ai
fréquenté beaucoup mais j'aime bien les
boîtes mais papa trop longue
parce que dans une boîte on n'a plus de
rapport
ça fait tellement de bruit que tu peux
pas mais je ne peux pas parler ici du
pain et dans alors qu'est ce que tu as
fait hier quoi je dis qu'est ce que tu
as fait hier un juge avait de la fièvre
non qu'est ce que ça va bien pour
draguer draguer en plus on drague et
c'est bien parce que ça faisait pas
besoin de parler tu as découvert tahiti
avec fernand raynaud et tu as dit là bas
chaque grain de sable me rappelle un
souvenir pourquoi tu as passé du temps
tu as laissé ton coeur à tahiti là bas
ah oui je suis un et sécurité je suis
resté deux mois et je crois que c'est un
des plus beaux souvenirs de ma vie
puisque le père de fernand était tombé
amoureux d'une tahitienne de 22 ans
celui avait 72 ans mais attends ce qui
est formidable c'est que la tahitienne
c est amoureux c'est pas par intérêt
parce qu'elle aime quelqu'un est le père
de fernand des qui a connu sept filles
on le voyait plus
quand on vous paye est dans la rue on
aurait dit un drogué le rythme est dans
la rue et et fernand le départ disais
bonjour je n'y répondrai après les
fermes en guinée t'as vu
cette co na va me tuer mon père au
moment de partir
tout le monde était là sauf le père de
fernand raynaud et fernande il
l'hydravion de partir à paris pour
trouver mon père y avait quatre
gendarmes à l'époque dans l'île on a
fait pour le lien on a retrouvé le père
qui pleurait la petite chlorés gilles s
pourquoi tu me laisses pas ça m'a fait
beaucoup de peine
je veux pas qu'ils créent vie civile
même si créative il va il va crever
d'amour et pas vous bien sûr il a ramené
de force
radi moi quand tu étais là bas et
ailleurs d'ailleurs tu adores regarder
des fonds je dois regarder des fonds
sans masquer son british un truc qui te
branche et paris pas de pêche jallet un
endroit où on allait j'avais un copain
d'haïtiens qui connaissait tous les
emplois et il y avait un dauphin qui
venait tous les jours qui se mettaient
contre moi et je caressais toi et tous
les jours il venait lui donner du des
poissons à la main comme ça et il savait
l'heure à laquelle j'arrive ici du monde
il a alors quand tu vis à wayne tu te
dis c'est très vive sous l'eau c'est
pour ça que c'est toi tu as cette
immense aquarium 1 avec de l'eau de mer
et passion de vue et le pacifique
les poissons tu leur donnes le nom de
tes amis c'est vrai ouais c'est vrai
qu'un cas de la gazzetta ça va toucher
tout ça je sais pas ça c'est
extraordinaire rien pas beaucoup oui pas
le cas parce qu'ils accueillent de value
teinte en poissons et de dix mois
cette histoire d'aquarium ça fait il
coûtait cher parce que tu t'es fait
arrêter à la frontière espagnole pour
trafic de drogue police et outils aux
grandes séquences à 1 ça que tu saches à
se former non j'avais je suis allé au
brésil qu'on avec belmondo et j'ai
trouvé des simples du sable blanc mais
blanc
plus blanc que sat moi j'ai dit faut que
j'y emmène pour moi l'aquarium où je me
met du sable le sable dans des petits
sacs en plastique ça c'est que c'est
vrai et puis j'arrive à l'aéroport
indira ils s'en souviennent encore
c'était simple site à orly je veux ma
valise et puis ils voient les petits
sacs de sable un édit qu'est ce que
c'est que ça justice et du sable et il
appelle le chef y avait monsieur
lefebvre il a lu sable et ramène du
sable j'ai ouvert à tous les paquets je
sais pas j'en ai dix kilos 1 15 kg et
j'en verrai pas engraisser tous les
paquets rien ils étaient 1
le chef c'est pas de la drogue car ils
sont la rue diderot ses filles
c'est vrai que pour les dégoûter de la
drogue flore organiser une chiche partie
qui les a rendus malades c'est vrai ça y
est tu sais que tout ça
oui mais je m'égare ans j'ai quelqu'un
qui provient peut ne pas dire le nom
un acteur connu
j'y vois là moi j'ai peur pour mes
filles de la drogue alors j'aurai vous
que ce soir on vient chez toi et puis on
fait une partie de moi j'en ai jamais
pris alors il dit j'ai peur pour mes
enfants dit tu as raison est la grosse
production
il ya vu le champagne
et je dis à mes fils on va dire ensemble
les noix fille et puis après je réserve
une surprise laissant votre merde
et qu'est ce que tu as sauvé ce je vous
dirai plus tard on la lit et puis
maintenant on va aller on va les fumées
du hcc papa tu fumes nuage hills à et
vient avec moi et j'avais dire mon
copain tu leur fais ou des cigarettes
mais que du haj pas mal comme des bêtes
alors elles sont arrivées d'enfumer
village moi j'avais fumé un peu alors
que je fais mais pas elles ont été
malades de moi aussi malade comme des
plaies et tu vois après ils m'ont dit
papa tu as eu raison de moi quand
j'étais petit à 18 mois à l'âge de 18
mois tu as eu la poliomyélite way et tu
restais appareiller jusqu'à l'âge de 10
ans 10 ans et c'est là qu'il a commencé
à faire l'andouille pour jour attirer la
sympathie les gens j'ai eu c'est un
drame dans mon enfance parce que les
enfants entre eux
très dur et à
avant de traiter de boiteux raté le bois
tout je voyais tous et tous mes copains
qui jouent au tennis qui jouerait au
football et moi je restais toujours à
l'école dans un coin et j'étais là j'ai
admiré parce que je ne pouvais pas le
faire mais ils me laissaient tomber un
peu et instinctivement pour les attire à
moi je commence à faire le coup
et une histoire formidable c'est
l'histoire de temps d'autant premiers
amours de vacances quand avait 9 ans à
autre salle dans le pas de calais et là
il y avait cette petite qui cernaient
s'appelait marie thérèse qui avait la
ville a en face de la sienne et tous les
matins quand tu ouvrez les fenêtres la
voyelle ouvrez les fenêtres on faisait
des sourires et puis un jour camair a
organisé une soirée cinéma et alors là
j'ai tout se faisait regarder
et puis que dès que la lumière s'est
éteinte a pris la main et le lendemain
qu'est ce que vous avez fait le
lendemain c'est tout ce que vous avez
fait le lendemain et c'est un film que
j'appelais qui saperait félix le chat
belle famille
et je me souviens toujours du titre et
le lendemain on était très timide on ne
parlait pas et le lendemain on s'est dit
on va se marier c'est mon fils et je dis
j ai dit mais tu sais il faut prévenir
les parents et elle m'a répondu on leur
dira quand on sera mariée on a réuni
tous les mômes du village on est allé
dans l'église du village qu'elle s'était
fait un petit voile de mariée et on est
rentré dans l'église très sérieux et le
curé nous a vu arriver ces cachets 1
il est venu voir ma mère avec les larmes
aux yeux ma vie est un diamant mais
c'est un peu un des plus grands
souvenirs de ma vie et quand on est
sortis de l'église
on est allé voir nos parents et on a dit
voilà on s'est marié le très beau comme
ça toi t'as un truc c'est que tu adores
faire la cour aux femmes en fait ça peut
être un jeune séduire tu aimes un appât
jambes à les séduire
non non pas pas même pas c'est dur parce
que on arrive à une époque
l'amour pour les jeunes c'est du sport
alors qu'il faut pas laisser ça comme ça
la mort il faut que ça soit romantique
même même si on on sait qu'on n'aura
aucune chance avec une femme c'est pas
pour ça qu'il faut être un bon
jaillissement j'ai toujours été très
juste raconter une chose moi j'ai eu des
aventures avec des femmes
ils sont venus chez moi ils ont passé la
nuit à la maison
je me suis rendu compte que pour me
faire plaisir
elle voulait elle voulait faire l'amour
pour me faire plaisir
mais quelle salle me disaient rien du
tout les gens on est toujours content et
je vous écris de fatima tu veux me faire
plaisir
mais si tu n'en as pas envie où s'arrête
la glissoire formule 1 tu as dit je n'ai
jamais essuyé deux refus de la part
d'une femme qui me plaisait jamais
jamais d'ailleurs la raison
enfin il a raison c'est que je me
rendais compte que c'était pas la peine
d'insister alors été marié quatre fois
dont deux fois avec la même pour evreux
marié avec la même et caridad les gens
j'avais pas vu depuis deux ans et puis
elle me dit ou agent je fais une bêtise
yaka victor j'ai des moments formidables
on avait un enfant vous conviennent
ensemble
et j'ai vu tellement malheur j'ai dit
pourquoi pas je savais que ça allait tu
sais quand tu as eu des choses
assez grave non dans un coup très
difficile de dragon de recommencer je
lui ai dit écoute mon meilleur ami et
puis on est ensemble ça dure et que
j'avais prévu j'ai prévu est arrivé
brigitte est un pas que je dise mais
c'est tellement beau de toute façon
brigitte et brigitte elle m'a draguée
avant le contraire noah un jour je
sortais du théâtre et était là
et puis vient vers moi elle me dit elle
j'ai découvert pièce vous savez j'ai
beaucoup d'admiration
parce que j'ai lu toute votre vie
j'avais écrit un bouquin qui s'appelait
pour que ça n'arrive qu'à moi vous êtes
vous avez un homme romantique des gens
aiment à paraty n'est commun comme un
homme peut pas rater une femme
des hommes comme vous il y en a plus
beaucoup et très touché joli très touché
et puis elle se décline à kiel revenu
régulièrement toutes les semaines
je m'attendais à la sortie du théâtre
et un jour
[Musique]
elle me laisse un petit mot
et elle parle
et je joue la lie vous lirez la lettre
quand je serais parti est parti j'ai lu
la lettre et l a dit carrément dans la
lettre à la fin j'aimerais faire l'amour
avec des toitures de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu